[Music]
on and on one of the most interesting
questions in tech right now is if you
were a smartphone maker and you were
making you're making a new budget phone
to sell for 400 bucks
basically you get to choose
one thing to make
special one one amazing feature about
your phone
and then the rest you have to save money
on
the question is
what feature do you choose
matter of fact let's play a little game
let's say you have 17 to build your own
smartphone not to buy but to sell and
you have a bunch of things that you need
to spend money on you know it's a more
complex list than this obviously but for
the sake of the game simple you have
limited money for five bucks you can
make something excellent special for
three bucks you can make it average and
then for one dollar you make things poor
just trash so my gut reaction is to make
a great screen like you got to have the
thing you look at be excellent and then
good specs i guess give me average
battery life and design
but then that's already 14 so that
leaves poor software poor marketing and
poor camera
ah
i want at least an average camera i mean
maybe that's just me but okay how about
great screen average specs average
battery average camera
then that leaves poor design
um poor marketing and poor software and
poor software is rough it's a
fascinating choice and obviously the
prices you know in our little game don't
line up with reality and there are way
more things you have to choose as a
smartphone maker but you can see the
list of trade-offs is a lot so i asked
this on twitter earlier today and almost
everyone responding uh spends one dollar
on marketing because
who cares about marketing your phone
nobody wants to blow extra money on the
phone for marketing but
they're they're answering from the
perspective of what phone would you buy
when this is supposed to be what phone
would you try to sell the most units
with and not everybody wants to make the
marketing trade off and spend the extra
money and give up the cut to carriers
and all that comes with the marketing
but you can see that's also a shift in
the trade-offs as well i think if you
did a poll of what most people care
about in a phone they're buying they
would say
software and camera are both pretty
important so as you're considering how
many you sell
you kind of have to trickle down and
start to lose features that aren't those
important things anyway this this is the
poco x2 this is the phone that got me
thinking about all this in the first
place it's the successor of maybe one of
the most hyped phones of the last two
years the original pocophone but this
one is again not coming to the us as
this phone but it converts to about 300
a little more than 300 us dollars which
is a great price for a smartphone
there's also the poco f2 and poco f2 pro
which is closer to 500 bucks but i
definitely want to get my hands on it it
looks impressive and the specs look
sweet and yet another example of how you
can make those choices in a budget phone
but i'm looking at the poco x2 the
display here is clearly where they're
spending some money seems like the
four to five dollar option you know it's
a 120 hertz 1080p display just about as
good and as fast as you're going to find
in a phone this cheap it gets plenty
bright too
it's big and it translates to just the
phone feeling super smooth all the time
which is great in any budget phone
and then on specs this phone has a
snapdragon 730 g
six or eight gigs of ram mine has six
ufs 2.1 storage so you know i'd say they
spent about their three bucks on specs
here you know it's not super high end
obviously it's not the 865 or anything
but it's also not trash it's average
specs what you'd expect to find here and
then the battery is a 4 500 milliamp
hour battery so that's nice that they're
not trying to go super thin or anything
crazy like that looks pretty decent on
paper but let's remember that's powering
a large 6.6 inch 120 hertz bright
display so that's something to keep in
mind but they did include a 27 watt fast
charger in the box so again it's feeling
like a
3
for battery then for hardware and design
this one's interesting you know they
don't really need to get too fancy since
they already have this nice screen to
lean on so essentially what we have here
is a redmi k30
like it's the same phone literally now
it actually says designed by poco on the
back but it's not it's designed by
xiaomi i don't know why i mean i
understand rebranding and i know you
want you can say poco anywhere on the
phone but designed by poco is a bit
weird either way that's what we're
working with and it's got the metal
rails the glass back it's got a nice
weight to it and it doesn't really creak
or flex at all when you twist it like
some other budget phones that are
plastic do
and the camera bump too is pretty
manageable it's not zero
so it does still rock if you try but at
least it's in the middle there is no
wireless charging even though it's a
glass back and they say it's splash
proof um but there is no official ip
water or dust resistance rating because
you know these things cost money but
look hardware design also includes
things like uh your headphone jack at
the bottom nice uh the vibration motor
bad in this phone not good
and also things like the fingerprint
reader here it's on the power button
here on the side which i like if you
have the choice between a crappy
in-screen fingerprint reader or
something else if you don't have the
tech just do it this way just do it on
the proven side of the phone where you
have to touch it anyway to unlock it i
like this overall that mixed bag feels
like another three for hardware and
design
and then speaking of that camera bump on
the back
quad cameras there is a 64 megapixel
main camera an 8 megapixel ultra wide
and then you add a depth camera and then
another 2 megapixel macro camera why who
keeps asking for these 2 megapixel macro
cameras is this do you just want to be
able to say you have quad cameras and
that's like the cheap one that you can
throw in to say you have another camera
and no one gets mad
but like no one uses it so why even put
it there i don't
i don't know another another depth
camera truth is though this phone's
primary camera actually impressed me for
the price it's not pixel level or iphone
se level good those are special but the
photos i took with it were usually
fairly detailed had nice dynamic range
and sharpness now as soon as you get to
less than ideal lighting noise
especially in the shadows cranks way up
and it never really knows exactly how to
deal with reds felt the most
inconsistent sometimes it over saturates
them sometimes it makes skin tones weird
but overall they definitely didn't skimp
on the cameras they're not the trash
cameras i've seen in some other budget
phones so i'll feel like that's another
three
then there's software the software is
myui 11 and just being honest i've never
really liked this skin and there's
nothing happening here to change my mind
with that now the nice thing about
android is you can change a lot of this
but it does take some work
but some of it is nearly impossible to
fully abandon also fun fact the dual
hole punch cutout for the selfie camera
is actually two cutouts with a software
oval drawn around and between them also
software as we know has an effect on
image quality and the camera so that's
like kind of tied to that just saying
now it's hard for me to say what they
spent on marketing because i'm not them
and i'm also not in the market that they
are
trying to sell this phone to but if you
just drop a one in there this phone that
actually adds up to the 17 that we were
budgeting with at the beginning so yeah
there's a lot of varying budget phones
out there right now this being one of
them this sparked my my conversation in
my head about it
that sounds a little crazy but that's uh
that's the high refresh rate one if you
want the budget phone with the higher
fresh rate screen potentially at the
expense of some other things this is the
one option you should be looking at but
the whole point of that game i tweeted
out earlier is there's a wide variety of
all these different budget phones
because there's a wide variety of
different answers that people give and
this is why the iphone se was such a
massive disrupter in this budget world
that's a 400 phone and when you fill it
out you go down the list it kind of
seems to mess with the balance a little
bit and even though apple doesn't have
to spend anything extra on the software
that software is super valuable for many
people super important having an iphone
for that price that's a big deal so when
it seems like you're going over the
allotted 17 points that's when it's a
good indicator that you're actually
getting a good deal i also look through
some other people's some notable
responses renee ritchie's he basically
built a pixel 4a kinda um go big on the
software and the camera
and then
you know whoops the battery is gonna be
kind of trash sorry uh mr who's the boss
spent extra on a great battery uh but
then maybe you have some concerns about
the software and also
by proxy therefore also the camera a
little bit this guy victor i saved his
tweet said the software is what makes
the phone usable so he spent more on the
software understandably
but then if you look at his list now you
have trash specs and
how usable is a phone after a year or
two if the specs are trash i like this
one the dave2d method spend all the
money on marketing and then don't
actually ship a phone
and superstaff straight up asks for more
money to make a better phone so
obviously it's a hard challenge and
there is no right answer but i would
love to follow up maybe if there's a
smartphone company out there willing to
share
this sort of information on like how
much do these different parts cost
remember when there are companies
leaving out nfc and their phones or
phones like this continue to leave out
wireless charging like how much does
each part cost and what are the
trade-offs for really putting together a
phone of a certain price obviously they
probably can't say how much the carrier
partnerships are worth but that'll be
interesting
either way i'm curious what would you
spend on each part of your ideal phone
i'll leave the the 17
question down below the like button if
you want to give it give it your best
shot in the comments
i'll hang out there and maybe give a
thumbs up to the ones you think you
would actually buy either way that's
been it thank you for watching catch you
guys in the next one
peace